Amani pull NBC Sports Bay Area Steve we
got the news on Kevin right before the
game started running from your point of
view first of all what your reaction was
to the news that he'll be reevaluated
again next week and second of all is
there a I guess a mental adjustment or
anything from going from wondering if he
might be back to thinking maybe he won't
be back in this series there's no mental
adjustment it's just you just play you
just you know you go out there with what
you have and you know we've this is our
third game three and a half games really
without them and and so we're just just
trying to hold down the fort and you
know hopefully he continues to progress
and he has made progress but you know
it's a little more more serious than
than we thought at the very beginning
and and so we'll see where it all goes
but he's in there all day long getting
treatment he's done a great job of
committing himself to that process Rick
and his staff are in there all day and
hopefully he'll be back at some point
but we'll just you know we'll just wait
and see